have you done ballet before um well i
used to be a stripper
we know cardi b can deliver a fierce
swap routine
now from the top make a job that's so
wet
but when it comes to classical ballet
let's just say
she's a work in progress the 28 year old
rapper dropped the first episode of her
new facebook watch series
cardi tries where we see her attempt
simple lifestyle challenges
first up a traditional ballet class with
iconic choreographer debbie allen
oh miss cardi b
[Music]
wow hi how are you
uh uh
oh uh cardi gets a crash course in
ballet positions plies
tandoos all that good stuff and while
she's no misty copeland she clearly had
fun with it
dibby plie bend your knees ah and
stretch
[Music]
[Applause]
and when it came time to try some across
the floor exercises
cardi put her best foot forward
literally
come on let's try and right leg right
whoops
[Music]
okay oh jesus oh snappity snap snap
but then debbie and cardi switched gears
pivoting from ballet
to african style dance mommy let me see
let me see mama look at you
you look real yeah yeah i'm ready to
give it to you now
judging by the big smile cardi was
clearly more in her element
cardi trying dancing is just the tip of
the iceberg
she's also gonna give teaching nursery
school and milking a cow
a go but up next we'll see her put the
pedal to the metal
race car driving with fast and the
furious star michelle rodriguez
i gotta see it to believe it